hi everyone David Griffin here we think
here calm here bring you another review
of Breaking Bad season five we got
episode 13 this week please forgive me
ahead of time for my pronunciation but i
believe it's too geely to Julie I my
Navajo is not what it used to be so i
apologize if anybody has any expertise
or any background on the reservation the
Indian Reservation that the show is
named after be great did a little bit of
research this part of the Navajo tribe
it's a section that the believe is west
of Albuquerque so that's what the I'm
assuming that's where the the the money
was buried in this episode were wall
buried as money so again besides the
title another great episode of Breaking
Bad keeps getting better and better
getting closer and closer to the end
it's too close I mean we had some funny
parts in this episode of the stuff with
you all you know with the whole shot of
Jesse with the brains being blown out I
mean that was just great strategy by
Hank and Jesse and his crew it was great
of course I love seeing Walt Jr trying
to learn more about the a one way and
have a day one day in a one business you
know taken over the Empire of car wash
services that they have but back to the
important things let's start with the
beginning Todd and Lydia like what just
I mean just what an awesome scene it's
it's crazy like I think she can sense
his affection towards her Todd is a cool
character he definitely needs his own
spin-off show I know it's not going to
happen but I would love to see his own
spin-off show it makes me sad this
series is about to end because I want to
see more of Todd he's so interesting
he's like he's almost like a little kid
even though I know his character is
young but he almost like a little kid
just kind of yearning for a parental
figure I mean like Jesse he kind of a no
calls mr. white has this great respect
for mr. white like I love when he's you
know making the you know he's making the
math he's like well Mr White said he
shouldn't breathing fumes mr. white says
this I mean he has great respect he's
almost looking for a parent figure I'm
assuming his band of brothers and family
members that he has those crazy guys in
his posse are definitely probably not
the family that the kid needs but I love
Todd I like his vulnerability it was
really cool the scenes with Lydia I
think Lydia again even though she's
crazy I was like to give her a lot of
credit
because I think she's super smart I
think Lydia senses Todd's affection
you'll bring her the tea and all that
and she's you know kind of using that be
like Todd you really need to do this for
me like this is really important to me I
think she can sense his affection even
though she's a little crazy she's also
smart she knows what's going on so just
a great opening I think that's one of
the highlights of this season even
though I know that beginning part may
not have been important as of course is
the ending which what we'll get to
eventually i think that was just-- i was
just a great scene the opening scenes in
this of this season before the credits
roll had just been some of the best of
the series i'm just loving it so far so
again let's go back let's move up a
little bit the planning you know done by
Hank and Jesse just kind of outsmarting
you know mr. white Walter we never
really see Walter you know panicking i
mean he's usually the one who's ahead of
everybody else i mean even Gus fring who
was the best you know bad guy that show
has ever had besides walled himself was
you know I mean what was a step ahead of
him while it's always a step of the
competition and now he's got his back up
against the wall I mean of course I mean
I guess who's got to get right to it
that final scene I mean I was so cool
even the drive there that was one of the
better driving scenes if I can call it
that I've ever seen into television so I
love just watching him you know blow
through Albuquerque you know just going
to the desert such a great scene i mean
the look on Walt's face when he realizes
that he's been outsmarted the look of
panic while a sitting in the car you
know and how bad are those people when
and what they're shooting that is some
of the worst shooting I've ever seen
those guys have all those guns aimed on
those guys in the middle of the desert
and they still can't hit anything I mean
that just go I mean that's just you know
it's television movies it wouldn't be an
exciting [ __ ] out of everybody died
right away so I can't wait for next we
can't wait to see what that what's going
to happen wouldn't be the ramifications
of that shootout I mean I I don't know
if it was just me like I'm not one of
those people who can look at a series or
look at a scene and be like oh I know
what's going to happen next but I'm sure
I if I sense something I'm sure a lot of
you did too so love to hear your
feedback on this during that whole scene
when what was being arrested I mean were
you sensing something was going to
happen I mean did you in the back of
your mind I mean you know that Walt gets
away you know that Walt comes from New
Hampshire you know Vermont wherever he
is he gets out so you know like in the
back your mind that Todd and his people
are going to come I mean I
this felt that like I'm just waiting for
the end of the episode I kept looking at
the clock the clock like I'm not here in
LA so I was watching like at six pm and
I look at the clock it's getting closer
to seven closer to seven I'm like well
when is this seeing it happen I know
Todd and his family are gonna show up
out of nowhere and they did and it's I
mean Breaking Bad always pays off I
think it's one of the few shows that I
think has the best payoffs i don't mean
the show has to have a big action
sequence at the end but i like that this
show does have a payoff I mean it builds
and builds and builds attentions always
building that does it for a reason in
the end you were awarded for that it was
just another great episode always a lot
of tension I mean again the focus here
is definitely that last scene but what
do you think about going back to be
waiting with the stuff with a Lydian
Todd I mean how do you see their
relationship going obviously stalking me
some full-fledged romance on there's
enough time for that but where do you
see that going where do you see Todd in
this where do you see Totten in Walter I
think Todd still has a lot of affection
for you know for Walt as opposed to
Jesse who's just a mean and Jesse to I
mean he's just he says he's so crazy
right now but he's so great aaron paul
is an amazing actor i love his wide-eyed
expression he's as wide eyes the whole
time during Walters arrest so I mean who
do you think we got some deaths next
week I mean they're in the middle of a
shootout who's going to make it who do
you think's going to survive this this
is this onslaught I'm this is going to
be a great shoot out already was a great
shoot out this was already another
excellent episode i love this season so
far again I'm just touching on some
highlights I'm going to hear some
feedback from you you know filming on
your favorite scenes you know was your
favorite scene hai me how do you think
about you know Walt Jr doing me this
stuff at the car wash learning what the
the a one way is but again another solid
episode love to hear your feedback and
as always please also tell me out with
the Navajo tribe stuff if any of you are
from New Mexico if you're from that area
if you have in you know back on you know
study on Navajo tribe let me know like
let me know if this title has more
context so I wasn't able to research
enough time to learn about the context
of the title if it had more to do with
the episode in just a location outside
of Albuquerque so please let me know
about that too but as always you know
you can come chat with us at thank yo
calm you can also come check to chat
with us on our YouTube page which is
right here think hero pro we're also on
Twitter if when talk to myself Dennis
any of us were at think hero if we talk
to me personally chat with me ask me
some questions you know chat some
breaking bad whatever shows you're into
right now i'm at griffin de and of
course we do have a facebook page and
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans